chaque dimanche les 1300 paroissiens de
voisins-le-bretonneux sont un peu à
l'étroit pour assister aux messes lancé
par le diocèse de versailles la
construction d'une nouvelle église dans
la ville devrait débuter prochainement
elle deviendra la plus grande église de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on a la chance d'avoir une communauté
paroissiale très dynamique mais
aujourd'hui on a éclaté sur sur trois
lieux et tous les moments forts de
l'année comme paca comme noël comme les
premières communions les confirmations
c'est des moments qu'on doit vivre
séparés en fait il manque une église une
église qui soit moderne à la taille et à
l'image de la ville nouvelle attendue
depuis dix ans le projet devrait sortir
de terre dans la future zone
d'aménagement concerté de la remise
l'église saint joseph le bienveillant
pourra accueillir jusqu'à 800
paroissiens l' architecture a été
confiée à un cabinet de rome le centre
au aletti c'est un cabinet qui rassemble
toutes sortes de corps de métier d
architecte bien sûr mais aussi des
sculpteurs des peintres des mosaïstes
pour porter de manière intégrale les
projets d'art sacré sa cabine et cafés
des mosaïques par exemple à lourdes ou
ailleurs et c'est la première fois que
la france fait appel à lui pour
construire une église où c'est un projet
assez innovant coût des opérations 7
millions d'euros entièrement financés
par le diocèse de versailles
plusieurs réunions publiques devraient
être organisées durant l'automne pour
présenter les premières esquisses du
bâtiment si tout avance comme prévu les
fidèles pourront fêter noël 2019 dans
leur nouvelle église